The following content is
provided by MIT OpenCourseWare
under a Creative Commons
license.
Additional information about
our license and MIT
OpenCourseWare in general is
available at ocw.mit.edu.
Today I will begin by talking
about a subject that we were
just getting to at the end of
class last time,
and that will be electrolysis.
And this is an interesting
topic.
One of the examples of
electrolysis that is commonly
used is that which forms the
basis for the so-called Dow
process.
Here, what I am representing is
a container.
And a container that would be
used to house molten magnesium
chloride.
If you take magnesium chloride,
which is a typical salt,
and get it hot enough,
then it will become liquid.
And when it becomes liquid in
the melt, what you can do is
carry out a non-spontaneous
reaction by applying an external
voltage.
So, the idea is that this is
some source of a potential
difference.
And you can take a positive
electrode and a negative
electrode and immerse it into
the melt.
And if the potential is
sufficiently great,
you can force a non-spontaneous
reaction to run,
because overall,
the reaction will be
spontaneous when you factor in
the potential difference of the
external source.
And, in this particular case,
the reaction that would be
taking place is as follows.
At one side we would have
magnesium two plus
ions being reduced to,
at this temperature,
liquid elemental magnesium.
So, metallic magnesium at one
electrode.
And, at the same time,
at the other electrode,
what would be taking place is
the oxidation of chloride ions,
two of which counterbalance the
magnesium two plus
in the salt magnesium
dichloride.
And we put in a couple of
electrons.
Sorry, we are oxidizing
chloride to Cl two,
which would be bubbling out as
a gas at the temperatures of
this melt.
You initially would have this
molten salt.
You would immerse your two
electrodes.
You would apply an external
potential.
And if that potential is great
enough, then these two reactions
start taking place at the two
electrodes.
And you can see that in order
for this to happen,
chloride is being oxidized.
And so we can see then that
this must be the source of the
positive electrode and electrons
will be going this way and going
down here.
And when they collect in this
electrode on the left,
they are used to reduce
magnesium two plus
to liquid magnesium.
So, that is an electrolysis
reaction in which something that
does not want to happen,
namely the reduction of
magnesium two plus
to magnesium zero by chloride
ions, that is non-spontaneous.
And we are forcing it to happen
by applying this external
potential.
And just how great must that
external potential be?
Well, Christine,
could you locate for me on the
table, there,
the potential for magnesium two
plus plus two electrons going to
magnesium
and the potential for
Cl two plus two electrons going
to two Cl minus?
Note that our standard
potentials that we defined last
time, relative to the standard
hydrogen electrode,
are always written as reduction
potentials by convention.
What is it here?
Can we zoom in on it?
Zoom in our finger.
Okay.
By the way, I had her do this
in part because I wanted to draw
your attention to this table
that is in one of the appendices
of the textbook.
So, it is in the back.
There is an abbreviated form of
this table right in Chapter 12,
which you should be reading.
But when you want to find a
standard potential that is not
in that abbreviated table,
you will now know that you can
go to your appendix to find that
reduction potential.
Christine, please read out to
me the value for the chloride.
Is that the one that you have
there?
+1.36.
Okay.
And this is positive of the
standard hydrogen electrode,
showing you that Cl two
is an oxidizing substance.
And then what about the
magnesium plus two
electrons?
-2.36.
Remember I mentioned last time
that elemental sodium was around
-2.7 volts, so it was a very
strong reducing agent,
magnesium.
It is also a very strong
reducing agent.
Chlorine is an oxidant,
so clearly the direction of
spontaneity in this system is
for a magnesium metal to be
reducing Cl two to make
chloride ions.
And that is why the form of the
salt that Henry Dow as a young
man was extracting from the
briny marshes near his home in
Michigan, and later founded the
Dow company on the basis of
chemistries like this.
That is how you found it,
as magnesium two plus,
2 Cl minus.
And so, overall,
if you reverse the sign of the
anode reaction and add it to the
cathode reaction,
you are going to see that this
one is downhill,
sorry, is non-spontaneous by an
absolute magnitude of 3.72
volts, which is the difference
between these two values,
this absolute difference in
potential.
That means that we are going to
have to apply an external
voltage of greater than 3.72
volts, positive,
in order to get this thing to
run and to be able to get
gaseous Cl two bubbling
out and in order to get liquid
molten magnesium to be formed
and separating from the molten
magnesium chloride.
That is a large external
potential.
That is the price that you have
to pay to make this
non-spontaneous reaction go.
And that is the minimum price.
If we could just briefly switch
to the Athena from the document
camera.
I want to mention this one
word, overpotential.
You will see an explicit
definition of the word
overpotential given in my notes
and in your book,
but what overpotential is,
in fact, a number.
And it is the amount of voltage
that is greater than this
non-spontaneous cell potential
that you have to apply in order
for the reaction really to start
kicking in and working.
In practice,
you choose maybe a couple
platinum electrodes,
and you dip them into the thing
that you want to electrolyze,
and you apply an external
potential.
And, in practice,
that external potential is
something much greater than the
cell voltage of interest.
And sometimes it is even a
large amount in excess.
And the reason has to do with
the barrier to the reaction,
that is introduced by the way
that it takes place at the
interface on the surface of
these electrodes,
so you have to apply some
overpotential.
That is energy that you have to
put into the system over and
above the inherent energy of the
electrolysis to make it actually
work in practice.
And so, the substance that we
would most like to be able to
electrolyze is water.
Because, if you think about it,
electrolysis of water would
produce hydrogen and oxygen.
And then we could have those in
our fuel tank,
and we can go ahead and let
combustion take place,
which produces what?
It would produce water.
You would get a beautiful
complete cycle,
if you could do a good job of
electrolyzing water into its
components, H two and O
two.
And the reason that that is
difficult is because you have to
put in energy,
somehow, in order to make that
non-spontaneous reaction go
uphill.
We would like to make that the
basis for the hydrogen economy.
I really love Iceland.
This is my favorite country,
I think.
Although, I have never been
there.
And it is, because they do this
reaction.
They do this electrolysis of
water every night,
so that they will have hydrogen
and oxygen for combustion
purposes the next day in their
buses in the city.
And they are actually doing
this.
And why are they able to do
that?
Well, their special location on
the planet gives them a lot of
free electricity that they can
use to run the electrolysis of
water to make hydrogen and
oxygen every night.
And then they can combust that
in their buses.
And you essentially have free
hydrogen, and it is not a
problem.
And in places like Iceland or
other places in the world,
where you have freely available
energy from geothermal sources
or from hydroelectric power,
then you can do that.
You can use that energy,
that electricity that is free,
that the earth is just giving
you, to go ahead and carry out
the electrolysis of water and
make hydrogen that way.
And we would like to be able to
do that using photochemistry.
One possible way to get the
positive holes in the electrons
apart is to use h nu.
A photon can impinge on a
material and lead to the
separation of charge in what is
called a photovoltaic device.
And, if you can interface a
photovoltaic device to a couple
of electrodes that have surfaces
that are appropriate,
chemically, for minimizing the
overpotential,
then you can use light coming
in from the sun to make
electrolysis of water happen to
get hydrogen and oxygen from
light that is coming in incident
on the earth.
And so, one thing that is
currently ongoing research in a
partnership at Caltech and MIT,
and I am involved with this,
this is Professor Nocera,
here.
And you will see this furry
face walking around the hallways
at MIT.
And he is an amazing guy.
And if he does what he is
trying to do right,
he is probably going to be the
next one in our department to
win the Nobel Prize.
So, Professor Nocera is
currently the professor of
chemistry and professor of
energy here at MIT.
He is the energy professor.
And he is a lot more voluble
and vigorous,
I think, than I am.
He is really bouncing off the
walls with energy.
And that is good because the
technical challenges that we
have to surmount in order to be
able to use sunlight to carry
out water oxidation,
water electrolysis are very
great, but they come down to
chemistry and to molecules.
And starting on Wednesday,
we are going to enter a part of
the semester in which we treat
the subject of bonding in
chemistry in quite a bit of
detail.
We are going to be talking
about molecular orbitals and
things like that.
And if you get a good
understanding of molecular
orbital theory and electronic
structure and the shapes of
molecules, you may be able to
contribute to this problem by
helping to design molecules that
can go on the surface of the
electrodes.
And the purpose of those
molecules is to reduce the
overpotential for water
electrolysis with sunlight as
the source of the electrons and
the holes.
And this man's entire life is
defined by one number,
and that is the overpotential.
We are making electrode
molecules that will bring down
the overpotential and give us a
free source of clean energy from
water.
One week from today,
you are going to have a little
introduction to undergraduate
research here at MIT.
We are going to have some
visitors who will come in and
talk to you about the 5
subject that is given during
IAP.
And the people who successfully
complete the 5.301 subject are
then guaranteed a position in a
research laboratory in chemistry
as an undergraduate research
opportunities program student.
If you want to get involved in
the molecular chemistry of
renewable energy,
then you might want to make
sure you are here on time for
class on Monday,
and you will get that
introduction.
And you can think about what to
do in terms of 5.301.
Now, I want to bring you up to
speed on some more important
concepts that pertain to
electrochemistry.
Let's talk about electrical
work.
Here, I want to make an analogy
to the way that electrons can do
work when they fall through a
potential difference and
experience a potential
difference.
I want to make an analogy
between that and the way that
things go downhill by virtue of
the force of gravity.
And so, you can think of a
waterfall of electrons flowing
from a place of high potential
to a place of low potential if
you want to get an idea for our
expression for the way that the
free energy of reaction is
related to electrical work.
And it is the total charge that
is passed multiplied by the
potential difference through
which the charge is passing.
We have been talking about this
potential difference and calling
it E.
And if it is standard
potential, then we will use the
superscript zero,
or the little degree symbol for
a standard.
And now, we want to know what
is the total charge?
It is going to be negative n
times the charge on the electron
times N sub A,
which is Avogadro's number.
And we are going to be
interested in getting the total
charge expressed in terms of a
quantity per mole.
Actually, we are going to
express it in Coulombs per mole.
And so, we combine e and (N)A
together.
And this is one of our
fundamental constants.
This is Faraday's constant.
And you will remember that that
is approximately 96,485.3
Coulombs per mole.
That is Faraday's constant.
And we will use that as our way
of expressing charge here.
And so, we get the important
expression, delta Gr is equal to
negative nFE.
And we will use that a couple
of times today in getting access
to other quantities.
And what is n?
That is going to be the
stoichiometric number of
electrons passed in the
half-reaction of interest.
I will show you a couple of
examples of how you figure out
what n is in this expression.
So, it is the total charge
times the potential difference.
One of the things that this is
useful for is for finding a
relationship between an
equilibrium constant and a
standard cell potential.
And we can do that by recalling
from chemical equilibrium the
expression that delta G is equal
to minus RT ln K.
And now we have a new
expression, down here,
for delta G.
And let's go ahead and insert
that, and we will see that nFE
is going to be equal to RT ln K.
And so, we can just rearrange
that and solve for quantity of
interest here.
We are going to see that the
equilibrium constant,
K, is equal to an exponential
of nFE divided by RT. And
this should be for a standard
potential.
And then this is the
equilibrium constant,
that special value of Q that
applies when the system is at
equilibrium.
So, let me put the little
superscript up here to make it
clear that we are talking here
about a standard potential.
The idea is then if you have a
reaction and you can express it
in terms of half-reactions,
then you can go to our table in
the appendix,
if those half-reactions happen
to be in the table.
And then you can calculate the
value of the standard potential
for the cell that would be
comprised of those two
half-reactions,
as we described last time.
And then, given these other
quantities, we can calculate the
equilibrium constant for the
reaction.
So, it is a useful thing to be
able to do.
You take a standard cell
potential and then take a
temperature like the standard
temperature, 298.15K.
And you have your value of F
that I gave you.
And you can look up,
of course, the value for the
gas constant.
And you have n,
from the stoichiometry of the
number of electrons passing
through this potential
difference.
And then you can get K.
And you see that this
equilibrium constant K goes up
exponentially as the standard
cell potential increases.
That is quite an interesting
relationship,
too.
And I would like to give you an
example of how we can use this.
Let's consider a possible
reaction of this sort.
This reaction,
of course, as you would see in
the table of standard reduction
potentials, is assumed to be
taking place in dilute aqueous
solution.
Actually, if it is in a
standard state,
the concentrations of the ions
will be taken to be 1.0 molar,
which is the standard
concentration.
One thing that I regret about
my lecture on Friday and about
my lecture today is that I am
not really talking too much
about molecules and molecular
shapes and what these things
actually look like in solution.
But normally,
when you have metal or
metalloid ions dissolved in
aqueous solution,
there is some number of water
molecules that are interacting
directly with the metal ions.
It is just not a so-called
naked metal ion,
but it is bonded to water
molecules in solution.
And this is through the type of
Lewis acid, Lewis base chemistry
that we talked about earlier.
There would really be some
number of water molecules bonded
here.
And we will look at so-called
coordination complexes in quite
a bit more detail in the
upcoming section on chemical
bonding, but this is how you
will find it typically written
in a book.
And that is not representative
of the structure in solution,
which you do need to know in
order to have a little bit of an
understanding of the system.
And we are going to consider
the possibility that indium may
react with uranium to provide
indium two plus.
We are going from trivalent to
divalent indium.
And the source of that electron
is the uranium three plus
ion going to the
uranium four plus ion.
There is a hypothetical
reaction that we want to
consider.
And we are going to need to be
able to express that in terms of
half-reactions.
And one of these half-reactions
is simply indium two plus
plus the electron.
Sorry, indium three plus plus
an electron going to indium two
plus.
And, similarly,
over here, we have uranium
three plus.
I am writing both of these as
reductions, as you will find
them in the table.
Four plus, plus an electron,
going to uranium three plus.
Those are our two
half-reactions.
Christine, can you zero in on
them?
Yes, you are doing that
already.
Thank you.
-0.49 for indium.
And then, when we look at
uranium, these are arranged
alphabetically.
Here they are in alphabetical
order.
In the tables they can be
arranged by potential or they
can be arranged alphabetically.
Sometimes it is easier to find
a potential by taking advantage
of alphabetization.
And so, if we can focus in on
that --
We focus in on that,
and you will see that the 4+
going to the 3+ is -0.61.
And then you will remember that
to find the standard cell
potential, E zero of the
cell is going to be equal to E
zero of the cathode minus E zero
of the anode.
And what we can see here is
that this reaction is going to
proceed spontaneously as written
because in going from left to
right, as written,
uranium plus three is going to
plus four.
So, uranium is the reducing
agent.
And it is a stronger reducing
agent than the other possible
reducing agent,
indium two plus,
because it is more negative
than the indium two plus.
And how much more negative is
it?
It is more negative by +0.12
volts.
And we, therefore,
because this cell potential is
positive, we know that this
reaction is spontaneous as
written.
And it is positive by 0.12
volts.
That is a spontaneous reaction.
And now we have all the
information that we would need
in order to get the equilibrium
constant for this reaction.
We know that,
in terms of standard potential,
it is 0.12.
Let's see, here,
if we can just calculate this.
All right.
I am going to take this and
zoom it a little bit.
We are going to put in
Faraday's constant of 96,485.3,
and also we are going to need
the gas constant.
Everyone remember the value of
the gas constant,
8.31447?
And now, if we look over at our
relationship between the
equilibrium constant and the
free energy over there.
We took a free energy and we
converted it into a standard
cell potential.
Now we have it,
so we want to solve for an
exponential of nFE.
n is one here because,
in both cases,
we have one electron being
transferred in the
half-reaction.
We have the exponential of F
times 0.12.
And then, that is divided by
RT.
And so we have R times 298.15
K.
And let me just make sure I get
back over here and get another
parenthesis in there and see
what it is.
Our equilibrium constant,
for that reaction,
with a separation for the
standard cell potential of only
0.12 volts, is about 106.
The equilibrium constant says
that the concentration of these
ions multiplied together divided
by the concentration of these
ions multiplied together is
based on the information
contained in the half-cell
potentials.
So, that was pretty cool.
And we will now go ahead and
talk about another relationship
that we can get.
Over there, I was able to give
you that relationship between
the equilibrium constant and
standard cell potential by
remembering something from
chemical equilibrium.
And now, we are going to do
that again.
And we are going to remember
that delta G for a reaction is
equal to delta G nought plus RT
ln Q.
That is something that
you should remember from your
studies of chemical equilibrium.
And the neat thing now is we
know we have another
relationship for the free energy
of a reaction that is related to
electrical work.
We got that up there.
Now we can go,
minus nFE.
Notice that what we are going
here is we are considering what
happens when we perturb a system
from equilibrium conditions.
And when might that happen?
Well, I showed you how to set
up a Galvanic cell last time,
and I showed you how to
calculate its standard cell
potential.
You could measure the standard
cell potential by using,
externally, a volt meter.
And, as long as you did not let
the reaction proceed to any
significant extent,
then you would know the
standard potential for that
cell.
And what we are going to do now
is we are going to say,
let's let the reaction proceed.
Let's let a battery become
discharged, for example.
And, as the reaction is
proceeding, we might want,
for example,
to be able to make a plot of
the potential at any particular
extent of a reaction.
And, in order to do that,
we will develop this equation,
here, that shows how the
potential at any particular
point along the reaction going
to completion is related to the
standard potential.
And all I have done now is
substitute minus nFE
and minus nFE zero
in, respectively,
for delta G and delta G zero
for the
reaction.
And now I want to go through
and divide by minus nF.
And when I do that,
I am going to get E is equal to
E zero minus (RT over nF) ln Q.
And this equation is very
central to electrochemistry.
It is the Nernst equation.
And you will be able to use the
Nernst equation to predict how
systems will behave when they
are perturbed from equilibrium.
And one example would be that
of a battery discharge,
like I was mentioning a moment
ago.
And so, let's kind of pick some
arbitrary material,
out of which to make a battery.
And we will use the Nernst
equation to get information
about how it will discharge.
And let's consider the
following cell.
It will be one in which the two
half-reactions are as follows.
Iron two plus plus two
electrons going to Fe metal.
And the other material will be
cadmium two plus plus two
electrons going to cadmium
metal.
Now we need the two standard
reduction potentials for iron
two plus,
--
-- which is coordinated in
aqueous solution to six water
molecules in an octahedral
array, but we will get to that
later.
And I can see the equation but
not the value.
And there it is at -0.44.
And now we need cadmium two
plus going to
cadmium, elemental form.
And we see that it is up there
at -0.40.
Both cadmium metal and iron
metal are negative of the
standard hydrogen electrode.
They are both reducing systems,
as it were.
However, we see that iron is
more negative.
And, since iron is more
negative, if we set the cell up,
if we have a piece of cadmium
on one side and a piece of iron
on the other side in this cell,
then this piece of iron metal
is going to be providing the
electrons in this system,
when we go in the spontaneous
direction.
The electron flow in the
external circuit will be from
the iron metal electrode to the
cadmium metal electrode.
And things happen in solution,
as we've discussed,
but that makes iron the anode.
And for the reaction going that
way, as we would have set it up,
then we have a standard cell
potential E zero of +0.04 volts.
And now, in order to apply the
Nernst equation to answer a
question about this battery --
and this battery is not a
high-voltage battery,
it is only 0.04 volts,
not high-voltage at all,
so you probably would not use
it for a battery,
unless you really only needed a
small potential difference in
the first place -- but,
nonetheless,
we want to know how we can use
the Nernst equation.
We can say, what is E at 80%
completion?
That is the type of question we
can answer using the Nernst
equation.
What is the potential drop to
from an initial positive 0.04
volts when the reaction is 80%
complete?
Under standard conditions,
we have one molar solution on
both sides of the ions.
So, in this solution,
we would have 1.0 molar candium
two plus,
and over here,
in this solution, we have
1.0 molar Fe two plus.
Because those are the standard
conditions, as you will see
written in the header to that
long table in your appendix,
because you have to define
standard conditions in order to
have a standard potential.
And the standard conditions are
1.0 molar of the ions,
respectively,
in solution.
At 80% completion,
what will happen is we will
have gone in terms of producing
iron two ions in
solution.
We are producing them in
solution as the electrons flow
through the external circuit
because the piece of iron metal
is the anode.
And so, what we are interested
in here is Q.
I am writing backwards.
Pretty soon I will be writing
straight down or sideways.
In the reaction,
as written in the forward
direction, we are producing Fe
two plus ions such
that we can define our Q at this
80% completion value as 1.8
molar divided by 0.2 molar.
And that is equal to,
of course, just nine.
Q is equal to nine.
We have RT, that will be 298.15
Kelvin.
RF is our number of Coulombs
per mole.
That is the Faraday constant.
And, in this case,
because in the half-reactions,
you have two electrons rather
than one being transferred,
n is equal to two.
If you plug in now,
you have E zero is 0.04 and you
have RT over nF ln of 9,
that will give you the
potential at 80% completion,
which is somewhere in between
0.04 and zero,
as this battery is discharged.
If you want to model the way in
which a battery is discharged,
you can use the Nernst equation
for that purpose.
But, there is another type of
cell that is interesting,
that you can also describe very
well using the Nernst equation.
This will be what is called a
concentration cell.
Concentration cells are pretty
neat.
In a concentration cell you set
up a potential difference with
the same electrode materials on
both sides, just different
concentrations.
If I were writing this in terms
of the type of diagram I used
last time, I could show you that
we could connect two beakers
with a salt bridge like that and
we could have electrode
materials here dipping into
solution on both sides.
And, in solution on one side,
we are going to have Sn two
plus,
divalent tin ions,
at a concentration of 0.01
molar.
And, on the other side,
we will have Sn two plus
at a concentration
of 0.10 molar.
This one on the left is dilute
by a factor of ten.
That one is the more dilute one
And we can ask what kind of a
voltage is set up as a
consequence of just simply
having different concentrations
of tin ions in the two beakers.
And we can ask in which
direction the electrons would
flow in a system like this.
Well, in this reaction,
the system wants to go from a
state where tin two plus ions at
0.10 molar
go to the beaker where we have
Sn two plus ions at 0.01 molar.
We have a potential setup here
that is similar to the way
osmosis takes place.
The ions want to move from a
region of high concentration to
a region of low concentration.
And the system would come to
equilibrium at that time when
the concentration is the same on
both sides.
And then there would no longer
be any potential.
The value of E nought for this
cell is equal to zero,
because we have the same
half-reactions that would take
place on both sides.
So, E nought is equal to zero
volts in the concentration cell.
And which way do electrons go?
Well, here is how you can think
of it.
The electrode material can be
made out of tin on both sides.
And, since tin ions are going
to appear in solution on the
dilute side, they are going to
jump into solution from the
electrode itself.
A tin atom that is a piece of
the metal on the surface of the
electrode will jump into
solution, increasing the
concentration of tin two plus
on the dilute side.
And, every time it does that,
we get two electrons racing
through the external circuit,
going over here,
where those two electrons can
be used to reduce tin two
ions in solution
that become a new tin atom on
the surface of the electrode on
the right-hand side.
That is physically what happens
to equilibrate the concentration
of tin ions on both sides as a
function of time.
And so, what we can find is
that these two values of the
concentrations go into
determining our Q in the
following way.
We have Q of 0.1.
Because the tin ions are going
from a place of high
concentration to a place of low
concentration,
and electrons are traveling
through the external circuit
defining the cathode and the
anode in the direction that I
mentioned, the electrons are
coming out over here.
So, the dilute side is going to
be your anode.
And we have n equal to two,
in this particular case,
because it is a two electron
process that converts tin two
plus into metallic
tin.
You can take these numbers and
plug them into the Nernst
equation.
And where you have E nought is
equal to zero,
n is equal to two,
T would be 298.15.
We know the Faraday constant
and the gas constant.
We have Q is equal to 0.1,
which is our concentration
ratio between the two sides.
And, when we solve that,
we are going to find that some
small voltage is produced
initially at this set of
concentrations.
I hope that in the last couple
of lectures, today and last
Friday, I have hammered home the
relationship between
electrochemistry and energy.
And next time we will go
forward in talking about
molecular structure and see how
that is going to play a role.